an Amazon delivery man is being praised  for following some unique instructions  on a novelty doormat surveillance video  shows Gilbert in Montana's at a Texas  home with a doormat that says please  hide packages from husbands he then  places the package behind a chair  homeowners Vanessa and Kenny O'Shea  bought the doormat a few weeks earlier  as a joke  we've had people put it underneath the  mat before but never try to actually  hide it so that was a first the couple  met their hero and praised him for being  humble and kind Montaigne said he  thought the request of the fat was  serious and he enjoys delivering  packages I'm getting one of those for my  really good friend